as somebody who's naturally shy shies
away from the spotlight how did you
handle those first few months of fame on
smallville i've talked to you about this
a long time ago
and have you learned to deal with it in
the in the decades later so
uh because i remember yeah handled it
terribly i really struggled
with it and i think
part of how i've handled it actually
this kind of ties back into what we're
talking about about overwhelm
i i kind of changed my life i i didn't
take
certain roles i didn't do as much press
i kind of pulled myself
away from the spotlight a little bit
because i didn't like
how famous we were when we were on
smallville yeah it scared you it wasn't
for you
i wanted all of it and you know tom
wanted part of it and
uh you know i think i want you know what
it was
it was nice to be on a show finally that
people were like you know they they
looked at you and it was
i i'm not gonna lie i mean when people
were like
you know they loved the character and i
could tell the writers loved the
character and the other cast members
appreciated my work it was just really
nice it was nice to get that sort of
feeling of like
hey dude you're doing something right
you're on a good show you're good
so yeah i mean it was kind of nice
good with people like i don't think
people scare you
like they scare me sometimes sure yeah
which makes it easier to deal with
people paying attention to you
yeah i'm an attention
you